turkish president recep tayyip erdogan
received the pope as his first official
guest in the new presidential palace
the move is unpopular with many in
turkey where the building remains highly
controversial a court ruled the massive
structure built in a former nature
reserve was constructed illegally
but pope francis accepted the invitation
from his host
he is expected to address the issues of
religious freedom and freedom of speech
christianity still lacks official legal
status in predominantly muslim turkey
the pope said it is essential that all
citizens muslim jewish and christian
both in the provision and practice of
the law enjoy the same rights
and respect the same duties
the pope said he wanted to see dialogue
and reconciliation between the different
religions to combat religious
fundamentalism
president erdogan criticized what he
called rapidly growing anti-islamic
sentiments appealing also for more
solidarity against intolerance racism
and discrimination
earlier pope francis visited the
mausoleum of the turkish republic's
founder mustafa kemal ataturk
the papal trip comes at a difficult time
for turkey as it weighs how to cope with
islamic state militants on its southern
border
pope francis expressly thanked ankara
for admitting 1.6 million refugees from
the conflict in iraq and syria and he
said it was a moral duty to help turkey
cope with the refugees